il y a ces traumatismes et c'est c'est
crimes terribles mais aussi ces
victoires
ukrainiennes surprenante comment est-ce
que vous pensez que tous ces événements
ont changé l'Ukraine et les Ukrainiens
au cours des 12 derniers mois cette
guerre creuse je pense que la consolider
la nation et la consolider le peuple
ukrainien historiquement tout le monde
sentent qu'ils n'ont pas de choix
historique que de continuer pour arriver
à la victoire pour arriver à la paix
juste pour restaurer les frontières de
91 pour punir l'agresseur et pour voir
des réparations de l'agresseur tout ceci
a souder tout un peu tout comme chacun
on espère et on travaille tous les jours
pour approcher le jour de la victoire et
votre travail
mediacent ça consiste surtout à
communiquer avec les pays avec
l'étranger l'Occident comment est-ce que
quelles évolutions vous avez vu dans
l'attitude des étrangers envers
l'Ukraine ces derniers 12 mois cette
année il a quand même nous a montré que
cette solidarité
occidentale avec l'ukrain c'est
visiblement renforcé donc on avait
commencé par l'aide militaire qui
consistait en 5000 casques aujourd'hui
on parle des avions de chasse qui
peuvent être livrés à l'Ukraine on voit
cette solidarité en termes de l'aide en
terme de soutien diplomatique en termes
de soutien financier tout pour au niveau
de rhétorique donc il y a aussi ce
soutien qui est là qui dit que la
liberté n'a pas de prix c'est justement
ça que tous les Ukrainiens ressentent à
l'intérieur de leur cœur et je pensais
qu'il y a des mythes négatifs sur le
crâne qui ont finalement été un peu
thermoli cette année oui par exemple le
mythe de des Ukrainiens donc le mythe
qui était véhiculé par la propagande
russe voilà les nazis donc la programme
russe continue à l'employé pourtant on
voit que c'est pas du tout ça c'est pas
du tout le cas et donc on espère que ce
mythe là il va se dissiper quand
on voit la manière tellement crue dans
ses employés maintenant par voilà une
poutine pour justifier cette brutalité
extraordinaire
je pense que ça ça finalement aidé
peut-être un peu tard à faire comprendre
au monde merci beaucoup c'est